[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire football on
rencontre inédite à versailles deux
sélections africaines la guinée les
comores se sont affrontés ce samedi au
stade mont boron dans le cadre d'un
match amical plus d'informations à
suivre
équitation pour la première fois de son
histoire le centre équestre sky
équitation située sur l'île de loisirs à
saint quentin en yvelines a organisé une
compétition internationale de confronter
les détails dans ce magazine walcoot
projecteur sur la transat jacques vabre
un rambolitains louis burton va
participer à cette course au large qui
va relier le havre au brésil l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 68
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football une
rencontre inédite à versailles deux
sélections africaines de football la
guinée les comores se sont affrontés ce
samedi au stade mob auront dans le cadre
d'un match amical nous rencontre qui a
attiré de nombreux supporters des deux
pays des images de patrick jacques de
dixmude un montage de jules grenier
ville
c'était la fête dans les tribunes du
stade mob auront de versailles dans le
cadre de la trêve internationale la
guinée les comores se sont affrontés ce
samedi en match amical
une rencontre inédite sur cette pelouse
qui a plutôt l'habitude de voir évoluer
des équipes de nationale 3 c'est festif
ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir de voir
le stade et les tribunes pleines et une
ambiance chaleureuse
rôle à qui les gens qui viennent
supporter leur sélection ça fait
vraiment c'est vraiment sympa au rendez
vous attirer des milliers de supporters
venus pour encourager leurs protégés et
surtout analyser le niveau de jeu des
deux équipes en pleine préparation en
vue des éliminatoires de la prochaine
coupe d'afrique des nations jouent en
ile de france y joue plutôt souvent
en espagne
en afrique nous sommes venus de
bruxelles uniquement pour ce match c'est
la patrie ça n'a pas de prix on après en
importe quelle distance gouverner la
booster pour la petite histoire les
comores l'ont emporté sur la plus petite
des marges sur le score de 1 but à 0 je
le succès rencontré pour cette affiche
la ville de versailles n'exclut pas
d'organiser d'autres rencontres
internationales dans les prochaines
années
on continue par du football mais cette
fois-ci de la coupe de france ont joué
ce week-end le 5e tour et les clubs
évinois n'ont pas été à la fête
voici s'est incliné 2 à 0 face à noisy
le sec où il s'incline également sur cet
écart face à adamois château a été sorti
aux tirs au but par mois après un match
spectaculaire ponctuée par un 3 3 seul
versailles échappent à cette journée
noire les versets il emporte 1 0 sur le
terrain de courcouronnes les joueurs de
la cité royale connaîtront leur
adversaire ce jeudi à 17 octobre du
football encore et toujours avec le
championnat de première division de
district ont joué ce week-end la 4e
journée où les buy-ins oasis se sont
séparés par un score nul et vierge 0 à 0
ouaddar s'ils l'emportent contre le ch
est née sur le score de 3-0 maurepas
s'impose face à hardricourt enfin à
voisins le bretonneux s'incline contre
sartrouville le championnat est toujours
dominé par maurepas qui compte quatre
victoires en quatre matches depuis le
début de la saison du rugby à présent
avec le championnat de fédérale 2 les
plaisirs en réussi à tenir en échec
gennevillois sur son terrain lors de la
4e journée du championnat
score final 20 partout un résultat qui
permet à plaisir d'occuper la 9e place
sur 12 avec un bilan d'une victoire un
nul et deux défaites depuis le début la
saison
l'objectif du club reste le maintien à
cette saison on continue à parler à de
rugby mais cette fois ci dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 versailles
fait du surplace les joueurs de la cité
royale promu cette année dans cette
division n'ont pu faire mieux que match
nul ce dimanche à domicile contre
vincennes lors de la 4e journée
un résultat qui n'arrange pas les verser
et qui pointe actuellement à la 8e place
avec une seule victoire au compteur on
écoute le responsable communication du
club pierre chevallier et sûrement
encore un peu tôt pour pouvoir tirer des
conclusions parfois n'a eu que quatre
matches on a en tout cas on est dans on
est dans la réalisation de ce que l'on
est ce que longtemps en fait c'est que
il ya une vraie différence entre
l'onu régional et la fédérale 3 au
niveau national peut-être en état
d'esprit une façon de faire évoluer à
changer on continue par du rugby dans le
championnat honneur l'union rugby centre
78 a perdu de justesse à l'extérieur sur
le terrain de clamart le leader du
classement le score 20 à 19 cette
défaite est un coup dur pour le club qui
a réussi son début de saison et qui
espère terminer dans le haut du
classement cette année les joueurs de
cyril mûriers sont pour l'instant
quatrième du championnat du basket à
présent le championnat de nationale 3
masculins trappe s'est incliné d'un
petit point face à roye et ce week end
le score 66 à 65 dans le derby non entre
marly le roi et le chesnais les joueurs
du chéné s'impose 84 63 le championnat
est toujours dominé par le chesnais et
trappes se retrouvent sixièmes du
classement
on continue par le championnat de basket
féminin en nationale 2 le chesnay
versailles est également en haut de la
fiche l'échiné ziane sont actuellement
première grâce à leur victoire du
week-end contre geispolsheim sur le
score de 69 à 52 elle compte désormais
quatre victoires en quatre matches
disputés à cette année amoa d'équitation
à présent pour la première fois de son
histoire le centre équestre skypekit à
sion située sur l'île de loisirs de 50
ans levin a organisé une compétition
internationale de concours complet
un triathlon équestre pour ses cavaliers
qui a réuni des centaines de
participants un reportage de mathilde de
2010 plus de deux cent trente cavaliers
étaient présents ce week-end pour
participer au premier concours
international de sky équitation trois
jours de compétition avec trois
disciplines différentes
le jumping le cross et le dressage pour
des cavaliers amateurs ou professionnels
venus du monde entier six nations
représentées des belges des italiens des
espagnols
un chilien alors on est assez
enthousiaste parce que on a monté ce
projet avec toute l'équipe du centre
équestre de saint quentin et les
cavaliers ont répondu présent et on a un
très beau week-end qui se déroule martin
vient du centre de la france
accompagné de son cheval diabolo dems
pour le concours de sky équitation leur
permet de clore la saison qui a commencé
début mars
c'est la première fois que je viens et
c'est aussi la première fois qu'ils font
un concours international et on est
vraiment plutôt enchanté de l'accueil de
là
des terrains de l'organisation dressage
le cros hier était très agréable à
parcourir et on mon choix le sait très
bien comportée donc c'était c'était en
plus très positif pour moi mais le cso
c'est cet après midi on va voir ça je
pense que c'est aussi un très beau
parcours
l'objectif de cette compétition est
atteint pour le directeur du centre
équestre qui souhaite à l'avenir et
garder ce concours et le développer pour
accueillir d'autres cavaliers ainsi que
de nouvelles épreuves
moi j'ai très à coeur qu'on garde cette
compétition internationale l'année
prochaine qu'on la fasse grandir
et puis qu'on continue surtout à
développer centre équestre poney club
puisque faut pas oublier que c'est ses
400 adhérents
maintenant qu'ils viennent pratiquer
l'équitation toutes les semaines qui
étaient là hier qui ont vu cette
fabuleuse compétition est ce qu'on a
envie nous c'est vraiment se monter ce
projet de développement ouvrir
l'équitation plus grand nombre proposer
des grands événements et faire en fait
que toute la famille cheval sur trouve
ici et pas désagréable moment un
triathlon équestre internationale qui
sera potentiellement renouvelée pour une
édition de 2020 avec comme objectif plus
de cavaliers étrangers du golfe à
présent l'open de france se déroulera du
17 au 20 octobre sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une date
inhabituels attribué par l'european tour
l'organisateur mais cette aide va
bientôt changer le tournoi va retrouver
la période estivale dès 2020 le
rendez-vous sera programmée du 2 au 5
juillet une bonne nouvelle selon le
directeur technique national christophe
muniesa on écoute ses réactions
on a travaillé avec le tour européen
pour faire en sorte que l'open de france
on trouve une date plus clémente dans le
calendrier et on est effectivement ravis
que dès 2020 l'open se déroule de
nouveau fin juin début juillet sa mousse
en boutade plus propice pour attirer
avant de penser à l'année prochaine
l'open de france 2010 9 débute ce jeudi
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les installations sont presque prêtes
pour accueillir cet événement majeur
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
en quatre jours les meilleurs golfeurs
français seront présents sur ce parcours
de l'albatros avec notamment victor
perez dernier français vainqueur sur
l'european tour ce qui sera le chef de
file de la délégation on écoute le
directeur du golf national paul l'ermite
edge au micro de tv 78 nous présente le
plateau de joueurs on a le vainqueur de
l'année dernière avec ce temps rennes
bien entendu ce qui est très positif
pour le public français
cette année c'est que comme on a
descendu deux catégories de rolex à un
tournoi classique sur l'european tour
ça ouvre des catégories pour les joueurs
nationaux
donc on a plus de joueurs français cette
année on avec thor perez qui vient de
gagner un énorme tournoi en écosse à
saint-andrews plus et bien sûr les
joueurs qui figurent en comment dire
très bien cette année qui sent dans les
top 50 européen qui sont là également on
va maintenant parler de boxe et plus
précisément d'un boxeur élan courtois a
dit la boum a dit il est toujours
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
boxeurs en activité à 39 ans il pourrait
viser un championnat du monde nous avons
la chance de recevoir a dit la môme
aviez sur ce plateau ainsi que son coach
temps guy farrugia bonsoir sort ça alors
est-ce que vous pouvez viser un monde
belge est viable oui j'espère mais
maintenant à 30 avant ça serait ça
serait je pense le summum pour moi enfin
en faire au moins un dans ma carrière ça
serait super je pourrais arrêter
tranquillement quoi qu'est ce que vous
en pensez et en rien est impossible on a
vu des grands champions devenir même des
français comme daniel ont grâce à
devenir à 40,3 en 40 devenir champion du
monde pourquoi pas
pourquoi padilha rien est impossible là
je n'ai pas un frein en boxe l'essentiel
cette voie là il est passé pro tard il
n'a pas fait beaucoup de combats
voilà il n'a fait cas il a fait de
quelques combats qui sont à ce niveau là
c'est quand même des combats durs mais
il n'a pas pris trop de coups là donc il
faut le voilà il est encore préservée je
pense que oui a une carte à jouer encore
vous n'avez pas combattu depuis le 3
mars 2018 contre nadjib mohammedi
c'est un handicap un handicap ou et non
après c'était
j'étais avec
mon promoteur malamine koné encore ces
derniers temps du moins ces derniers
temps cette époque c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas eu de combats qui avaient pu être
mis en place donc du coup ça a suivi son
cours en voilà aujourd'hui je suis plus
en janvier de revenir je me fais
toujours aussi plaisir sur le ring comme
à la salle dont je veux revenir voir
encore pour pouvoir obtenir différents
différents points et puis me remettre
dedans classement mondial vu que c'est
mon dernier combat encore j'étais dans
les 20 ou 30 premiers donc quelques
combats deux reprises pour me remettre
dans ce fameux classement et puis
pourquoi pas finalisé avec une belle
petite ceinture mondiale
après ce combat vous pensez à la
retraite pas du tout dans votre tête
c'était pas du tout le cas c'est wayne
on sait pas le cas tant que j'aurai
encore cette envie je le ferai voilà si
ma fille m'a dit par contre d'arrêter
j'arrête
tanguay qu'est ce que vous en pensez
l'otan va aller jusqu'au bout du
parcours on a fixé l'objectif est cette
fin de championnat du monde après on
verra
il ya des propositions déjà ou pas il ya
beaucoup de gens qui parlent
on l'a beaucoup de gens que j'ai parole
maintenant et il faut du concret vous
confirmez vous confirmer après je
l'entends pas tout tout c est qu après
c'est vrai que c'est très souvent
l'entraîneur ou bien on essaie de vous
prendre un peu en individuel mais moi je
je me contente que du concret voilà je
me fais plaisir ça vient c'est très bien
ça ne sagna pas en france en ce que ça
devienne alors vous avez remporté les
titres de champion d'europe mais jamais
non pour l'instant non pourquoi pas de
monde parce que tout simplement le le la
plus un des plus grands combats ça a été
j'ai fait un comment j'ai fait une
ceinture
l'afo j'ai boxé piano smith on a boxé
pour ma ceinture européenne et pour être
pour pouvoir justement faire un combat
championnats du monde ce qui qui
remportait combat faisait un championnat
du monde mais c'était pour une église je
vois ça a été un tournant dans votre
carrière
vieux j'ai perdu le combat ça a été
difficile donc
j'ai pas pu viser cette fameuse ceinture
mais par la suite il ya eu peu de choses
on a récupéré titre européen et puis
là on va revenir sur les bandes voilà
c'était en 2016 est ce que ça a été un
tournant dans la carrière d'adil hamouma
dit à votre avis tanguy un tournant dans
la toujours on va dire ça ralentit la
chose mais ça va pas tourner il est
encore là voilà il pleure prétendant
parler des classements mondiaux il peut
reprendre
ils peuvent ça dépend de les
opportunités qu'on nous propose
il a encore craqué justement est ce
qu'elle dit la môme a dit n'est pas trop
craint justement dans le monde de la
boxe
vous affichez points sans adil hamouma
10 23 victoires dont 16 par ko 5
défaites et un nul
est ce qu'il ne fait pas trop peur
finalement un deal abou madi est ce que
justement ça a peut être un peu freinée
en sa carrière si en angleterre on parle
encore du combat qu'il a fait et devant
qui s'appelle de galles s'arrêter voilà
même des mêmes déjà reçu un coup de
téléphone
aujourd'hui c'était hier soir des
américains qui cherchent un combat pour
marvin à 60 kg entre parenthèses et un
petit travail à marvin petit qui est
également j'ai là j'essaie de passer a
dit là et puis et le ce combat-là est
ressorti dans la discussion
quelqu'un qui gère la carrière de qui
s'occupe des plateaux de mayweather
donc c'est quand même un combat qui fait
partie des annales aujourd'hui de la
boxe et
on a quoi la dynamo m'a dit comment vous
entraîner en ce moment dans ce moment on
reprend j'ai souvent dit un plaisir
vraiment plaisir venir la salle à bord
mais mais mais mes entraînements
quotidiens à revenir tous les jours à la
salle est basse et tous les jours
là j'ai repris le rythme de tous les
jours au minimum une fois voilà ensuite
quand il y aura des choses plus
concrètes on va on va multiplier les
entraînements par jour
dès ma question a dit là qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter un championnat du
monde avant la fois pas peut-être pas
cette année au mois fin de ma carrière
année jeu j'y crois bien je le sens je
sans fin en tout cas je serai prêt j'ai
toujours cette envie gagner bien sûr
apprécié à l'heure du moment où on fait
ou on part sur un challenge comme celui
ci mentalement on s'y prépare donc on se
prépare très souvent à 99% pour la gagne
au contraire
sinon le fait pas merci à tous les deux
d'être passé sur ce plateau on continue
à vous suivre a dit là où on m'a dit on
espère un titre mondial dans les
prochaines années peut être prochains
mois peut-être prochain bat et on
continuera à suivre la ti farrugia à
elancourt on prend maintenant la
direction de plaisir la bike and run de
la ville était organisée ce dimanche
matin des centaines de concurrents
participent à cette course ou un duo de
vet'affaires alterné entre le vélo et la
course à pied sur plusieurs kilomètres
cette année la ville proposait plusieurs
parcours dont un 15 km 1 8 km adultes
pour le 15 km c'est le duo camille à
biner et arnaud tu auras du poids sites
réels clan qui l'attend pas qui l'a
emporté cette année la ville devrait
organiser une cinquième édition en 2020
direction maintenant le vietnam pour
parler d'une autre compétition celle du
raid des amazones la 20e édition de ce
rendez vous entièrement féminin a débuté
ce lundi en asie parmi les 314
concurrentes une yvelinoise romy fourni
originaire de carrières sous poissy et
participe en ce moment même aux épreuves
après le canoë aujourd'hui elle va
tenter avec sa soeur de réussir les
autres épreuves au programme comme le
tir à l'arc le vtt ou le trail 7000
places au run and bike
les deux sportifs sont pour l'instant
92e du classement fin de l'aventuré
dimanche prochain tentera d'avoir remis
fournier en plateau dans une prochaine
et
sion on continue à parler de football et
plus précisément de vince qui selon le
vous dit peut être rien mais c'est un
youtuber ultra connu dans le monde du
ballon rond et il est originaire de
buchelay ce sportif a notamment fait des
vidéos avec florian thauvin cristiano
ronado ou encore sergio ramos réac ça il
a également fait des vidéos en réalisant
des défis mais depuis la rentrée winski
s'est lancé un nouveau défi celui de
créer une équipe de football dans sa
ville baptisée vinik vince tfc il a fait
une vidéo pour expliquer ce choix dans
les yvelines dans 78 en région
parisienne du coup alors pourquoi tu as
demandé pourquoi ce sont 18 parce que
moi là bas je suis un mec qui vient de
buch les airs vous à verser quoi bûcher
voilà c'est pas connu c'est un petit
village tu aimes pas combien on est à
buchelay 3127 habitants en 2016
c'est là où j'ai grandi voilà c'est que
j'étais en école primaire je suis allé
dans une ville à côté qui s'appelle
magnan vie au collège et au lycée mont
région parisienne tous les terrains sont
utilisées par des clubs des associations
etc
et c'est très compliqué de trouver un
créneau très très très compliqué j'ai
contacté monsieur martinez qui est le
maire de buchelay j'ai proposé le projet
il a adoré il a qui fait le projet il a
envie de soutenir à fond notre
initiative donc là quand j'ai vu ça je
me servais ont redonné du baume au coeur
parce que tu arrivais semaine que
j'essaie de trouver un terrain que
j'avais des réponses négatives mais le
problème c'est que à büchel a pas de
terrain de foot donc là j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu décomposé comme a dit
ça je suis dit mais en fait la tuerie
qui auront pas ce que je veux dire ma du
tac épaves niscayah un projet sur le
long terme où j'ai envie de créer un
terrain de foot à buchelay
ça nous en parlerait dans une autre
vidéo je vous montrerai concrètement les
terrains ce que mon là je suis dans mon
studio
mais en attendant on va trouver des
villes qui peuvent vous accueillir en
attendant vous évolueront donc à mantes
la jolie kate une ville juste à côté de
buchelay bon là c'est vraiment une vie
pour le coup ci a beaucoup plus
d'habitants dans un complexe sportif
s'appelle la bu deux verres on aura un
créneau hebdomadaires d'entraînement le
dimanche les matches mais des fois à
domicile ça sera du coup à mantes la
jolie et à l'extérieur ce sera dans la
ville bacon affrontera vince qui espère
faire monter le club en ligue 1 dans
treize ans ce n'est pas forcément gagné
pour le premier match de son histoire le
fc vince qui s'est incliné 4 à 2 sur la
pelouse du mans tu olympiques et il
s'est de nouveau inclinée ce week-end
face à porcheville sur le score de 1 but
à 0 le club se retrouve 8e sur 11
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
on va parler de voile et plus
précisément de la transat jacques vabre
un rambolitains louis burton va
participer à cette compétition au large
qui va relier le havre au brésil le
navigateur sera en duo avec l'un de ses
amis de toujours davy beaudart nous les
avons rencontrés lévy noah patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images jules
grandes villes pour le montage à mes
côtés le rambo lutins louis burton que
nous avons réussi à avoir juste avant
son départ
on est à paris et il est prêt il est
prêt louis burton
oui bonjour à tous ainsi toujours un
plaisir de venir en ile de france on se
voit régulièrement avant les départs de
course on est à 15 jours du départ de la
jacques vabre et on est prêt avec bureau
vallée on est prêt avec des vies
il reste encore quelques petites choses
à caler notamment les rendez vous avec
les sponsors les médias etc
mais non c'est c'est la partie sympa du
boulot donc le départ c'est le 27
octobre
qu'est ce qui reste à faire dans ces 15
derniers jours alors on va partir de
saint malo pour monter au havre au
départ de la transat jacques vabre
le 10 est donc la semaine prochaine
entre temps on doit encore faire nos
sacs de vêtements on doit faire nos sacs
de nourriture vérifier que on a
suffisamment de gaz vérifier tous les
derniers petits aspects logistiques
qu'on repousse un peu d'un des moments
parce qu'on priorise d'abord sur la
préparation du bateau donc là on est
vraiment sur les tous derniers
préparatifs
ces bateaux il est cohérent alors c'est
un bateau qui a gagné le dernier vendée
globe
c'était l'ancien banque populaire c'est
un bateau qu'on a pu améliorer encore
cette année pendant le chantier d'hiver
on à m'aider me des systèmes qui
permettent de régler les feuilles les
donc d'améliorer encore les performances
c'est un bateau qui devrait nous
permettre de jouer en tête cette année
pendant la transat jacques vabre mais on
espère jean pas que j'en parle trop
parce que faut pas porter malheur mais
c'est c'est vraiment une belle machine
l'année dernière vous aviez avoir donné
assez tôt est ce que cette année vous
êtes plus confiant alors c'est vrai que
ça la route du rhum après c'était sur la
route du rhum 2018 c'est c'est toujours
un grand coup dur quand on ne peut pas
aller au bout d'une course ça avait duré
12 heures
l'année dernière cette année on a
renforcé tout ce qui pouvait à nouveau
cassé tout ce qui était calculé un peu
trop léger aujourd'hui on a un bateau
qui est fiable normalement après ça
reste un sport mécanique donc
c'est un peu comme en formule 1 ça va
être à nous de gérer pour pas appuyer
trop sur le bateau quand la les
conditions de mer sont trop difficiles
il faut terminer et
idéalement terminé en étant le plus
devant possible cette transat ça
représente quoi pour vous la transat
jacques vabre donc ça va être ma
cinquième participation d'affilée
c'est une
une course mythique elle existe depuis
longtemps et c'est une course
que moi j'adore personnellement parce
qu'on l'a fait en double on est très
souvent solitaire sur nos bateaux et et
de faire une course à deux c'est sympa
en général et ça permet de d'exploiter à
120% les bateaux puisque pendant qu'il y
en a un qui veille et qui règle le
bateau l'autre d'or se repose donc voilà
c'est une course très dure mais
mais que j'affectionne particulièrement
parce qu'on est deux à bord vous serez
avec comme coéquipier dans le bateau
vous serez avec davy beaudart qui glisse
et davy beaudart on connaît pas
forcément le grand public ne connaît pas
forcément
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un en qui vous
avez confiance alors davy beaudart oui
c'est un ami de longue date puisque on
s'est connu sur le circuit
hier c'est donc les régates en habitable
quand on avait 18 ans on a le même âge
on est
marié tous les deux on
on a deux enfants on a vraiment un
parcours de vie communs donc dans toute
la préparation se comprend
ou les partager un événement de ce type
ensemble oui oui c'est vrai que en fait
des villes et il est très bon sur lomé
depuis à peu près 15 ans il fait ce
qu'on appelle la mini transat qui vient
de partir là et ça tombe toujours
pendants les transats jacques vabre et
donc on n'avait jamais pu partir et
cette année il faisait pas la
mini-transat donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion pour pour lui proposer cette
course et c'est un binôme qui qui j'ai
confiance je sais qu'il prendra son moi
je sais qu'il a l'objectif d'aller le
plus vite possible
et puis dans la vie professionnelle il a
il a un chantier naval est donc
techniquement il est il est vraiment au
point sur l'eau vous allez être
complémentaires alors on est assez
complémentaire dans la préparation sur
l'eau on est on est complémentaires en
tout cas on ne peut pas vraiment dire
qu'on soit complémentaire on fait tout
ensemble et à 2 on a tous les deux des
parcours de 2
skipper solitaire donc on va plutôt
confronter nos points de vue et puis nos
prises de décisions et et c'est ce qui
rend d'ailleurs cette navigation avec
lui si intéressante la préparation tout
s'est passé comment justement alors on a
dû déjà
réparer bureau vallée suite à la route
du rhum ça a été ça a été un gros
challenge parce qu'il y avait eu facile
vous rappeler mais il y avait une voie
d'eau très importante
j'avais embarqué plusieurs tonnes d'eau
à l'intérieur du bateau
il ya eu sept mois de chantier jusqu'au
mois de juin à peu près de préparation
et ensuite ça a été des navigations de
la mise au point des navigations de la
mise au point ça c'est sur la partie
partie nautique à une course importante
qui est le fastnet qu'on a couru en août
où on a terminé quatrième et ensuite
beaucoup de préparation sur l'eau qui
n'est à terre pardon sur le kiné ostéo
coach sportive enfin voilà histoire
d'être à peu près en ligne aux formes
pour un bateau de
de cette puissance est ce que cette
transat jacques vabre est une
préparation pour le vendée globe ou est
ce que c'est un objectif en soi terminer
dans le top 5 alors au top 3 c'est un
objectif en soi puisque c'est à mes yeux
la troisième course la plus importante
du plateau après le vendée globe est et
la route du rhum donc il ya vraiment de
l'enjeu on est attendus sur cette course
on va être une trentaine de bateaux de
la catégorie imoca et puis c'est une
course qui en même temps en effet va
nous servir à se jauger contre les
autres pour le vendée globe puisque
quasiment tous les nouveaux bateaux qui
vont courir l'année prochaine autour du
monde sont sortis donc on va pouvoir
ben voilà voir qui qui va plus vite
potentiellement qui va moins vite et et
se mettre à jour par rapport aux
concurrents pour l'année prochaine mais
vous y serez sur la glace oui on y sera
avec dorval et pour la troisième année
consécutive troisième édition
consécutive les victoires sont
envisageables sur cette transat jacques
vabre selon vous où ça risque d'être
encore un petit peu juste il faut pas
faut pas faire de pronostics comme ça
mais parce que ça porte malheur
on est un peu superstitieux dans la
voile mais oui on a on a un bateau qui
peut permettre de jouer devant et
et on s'est beaucoup entraîné cette
année donc on a ça quelque part dans un
coin de notre tête
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
cette transat de terminer déjà d'arriver
au brésil c'est important même pour se
remettre de la route du rhum ça ça a
vraiment beaucoup d'importance d'aller
au bout et puis ben d'être entre
cinquième et premier on sera content
merci beaucoup
burton la transat jacques vabre c'est le
27 octobre départ depuis le havre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]